if as prime minister there is a topic
you want to kill at pmqs you do so by
addressing it fast and after days of
speculation about Rishi sunak's use of
Private health care he used today's
first question about NHS Dentistry to do
exactly that
I am registered with an NHS GP I have
used independent Healthcare
I'll answer her question I've spoken to
number 10 and they won't say when Mr
sunac stopped using private healthcare
it possibly happened after he became PM
now Kia stalma didn't have much of a
choice of topic today he had to go on
Industrial action as expected he
criticized the government's new
anti-strike legislation and focused on
the group of Strikers that polls suggest
are most popular with the public
they've gone from clapping their noses
to sucking the nurses it's that simple
why is he choosing to prolong the misery
rather than end these strikes after 13
years in government what does it say
that the best they can offer is that at
some point they might stop making things
worse
[Applause]
in response to that Rishi sunak
continued to use three key messages the
independence of the pay review bodies
what he claims is a lack of Labor policy
and that party's closeness to trade
unions
he talks about wanting to end the
stripes the question for him is simple
then why does he not support our minimum
safety legislation
we all know why we all know why Mr
Speaker it's because he's on the side of
his Union paymasters not patience
throughout these exchanges Shadow
Chancellor Rachel Reeves continued her
role and as heckler-in-chief I tell you
what the NHS doesn't need what they
don't need you she shouted if we watch
again and focus on the labor benches we
can see the chorus of gesticulations and
perhaps it was that that really
irritated the PM because we saw Richie
sudanak's tone markedly change
again again it's just
I just absolutely no understanding of
the situation Mr Speaker what happened
to cancer referrals during covid they
went down by almost two thirds Mr
Speaker that was because of a pandemic
that they went down and by the way if we
had stayed and listened to him we'd
still be in lockdown and there'd be a
bit more waiting
the SMP focused on Sky's Westminster
accounts project and Boris Johnson's 1.2
million pounds of outside earnings
let's reflect upon numbers and in
particular those numbers that were shown
away on by Sam Coates of sky in
particular those in relation to the
prime minister's favorite potential
successor which showed that over the
course of four months from four speeches
he ripped in in excess of a million
pounds
um well Mr Speaker I did I don't think
we need to talk about our predecessors
but I reckon I remember I remember
it was one of his predecessors that did
indeed work for Russia today if I'm not
mistaken a reference there to Alex
salmond Now Matt Hancock is a bit of a
divisive figure in the Commons so he
kindly chose to ask a question on an
issue that would unite the chamber
comments by this man Tory MP Andrew
who today had the party whip removed for
spreading misinformation about covert
vaccines and comparing them to the
Holocaust
the the disgusting anti-semitic
anti-vaxx conspiracy theories that have
been promulgated online this morning are
not only deeply offensive but
anti-scientific and have no place in
this house or in our wider Society
obviously it is utterly unacceptable to
make linkages and use language like that
and I'm determined that the scourge of
anti-Semitism is eradicated it has
absolutely no place in our society
and one fact to leave you with Andrew
bridgen and Matt Hancock are among 15
independent MPS in the House of Commons
there are now more of them in Parliament
than liberal Democrats